je déteste par ici ville que j'ai en
horreur depuis toujours je la trouve
l'aide je la trouve sale je la déteste
mais j'aime beaucoup la plupart des gens
qui habitent mais la ville en elle-même
je la trouve atroce c'est une des
capitales les plus laides du monde et de
très loin votre question c'est est-ce
que c'est vrai oui j'ai eu des débuts
qui étaient extrêmement punk j'ai dormi
à bobbourg pendant plusieurs semaines
où j'avais une vue tout à fait similaire
à celle là parce que je me levais à
l'aube et donc il y avait ce décor
j'habitais à l'époque dans un squat à
Levallois
avenue au rue Louise-Michel je sais plus
s'il est venu une rue Louise Michel je
crois au métro Louise Michel et puis à
un moment donné
un des amis un des lieutenants de
Jacques Mesrine
m'a effectivement complètement par
hasard un soir proposé de de m'héberger
en fin de donner un apport hémiplégique
pas grand chose à l'intérieur
c'était une plante
alors effectivement c'était une plante
qui manquait plus que les rats mais il y
avait des pigeons crevés quand même à
l'intérieur mais j'ai fait le ménage et
ensuite j'étais pas j'étais pas mal
là-dedans je crois savoir que tous les
jours à 5h habitude prise d'ailleurs
depuis l'armée vous nagez le matin euh
non c'est pas forcément le matin mais je
nage tous les jours je fais 3 km 300
tous les jours de crawl
tous les jours tous les jours c'est une
discipline c'est salutaire c'est une
religion c'est ma seule manière de prier
c'est
nager parce que quand on nage on
s'ennuie au bout de 10 minutes surtout
moi qui devient intérieure assez pauvre
je m'aperçois qu'en fait au bout de 10
minutes j'ai épuisé tous mes propres
sujets de conversation donc pendant 50
minutes à peu près je suis plongé dans
l'ennui mais l'ennui c'est un luxe dans
une société qui veut toujours se
divertir l'ennui et quelque chose qui
est devenu une denrée extrêmement rare
donc moi j'ai la chance de pouvoir
m'ennuyer
50 minutes par jour vous avez dit
souhaiter la mort de la totalité de
votre famille ces jours-ci à l'exception
de votre grand-mère
je vois pas ce sont des [ __ ] des ce
sont des gens qui auraient dénoncé des
juifs pendant la guerre ce sont des gens
qui sont d'extrême droite ce sont des
gens qui ont voté Jean-Marie Le Pen
depuis toujours ce sont des gens que je
méprise sont des racistes ce sont des
homophobes ce sont des sales gens sont
des gens qui ont essayé de détruire mon
existence sur des gens qui maltraitaient
les animaux sur des gens qui
maltraitaient un de leurs enfants voilà
quoi cette famille vous la placez dans
la seule catégorie de géniteur mais si
elle vous demandait pardon
je crois Nathalie que vous ne savez pas
qui vous avez à faire
imaginez
imaginez-vous par exemple que vous ayez
passé une nuit sur deux en pyjama ou en
slip
dehors imaginez qu'en plein milieu de
votre sommeil à l'âge de 11 ans vos
parents vous ai emmenés dans les bois et
vous ont fait croire qu'ils allaient
vous y abandonner pendant une heure et
demie ou deux heures imaginez que au
moment où vous jouez avec un ami tout
d'un coup on vient vous arracher au jeu
pour vous donner des coups de rallonge
électrique et imaginez que ce cirque est
durer jusqu'à l'âge de 14-15 ans
imaginez que tous les romans que vous
avez essayé des priorités brûlés sous
vos yeux imaginez que toutes les bandes
dessinées que vous avez voulu créer et
était déchirés ou brûlé sous vos yeux et
imaginez que l'intégralité des Pléiades
que vous êtes offerts avec votre argent
de poche et fini au panier ou au feu
imaginez que lorsque vous préparez si en
SPO une semaine avant le concours toutes
les fiches que vous avez préparées
pendant 6 mois étaient détruite pour pas
que vous vous irez réussissiez le
concours imaginez aussi que le jour où
vous rencontrez une petite amie pour
peut-être avoir votre première
expérience amoureuse votre propre mère
vienne dire cette petite amie que vous
avez déféqué dans votre culotte jusqu'à
l'âge de 12 ans et demi si vous pensez
que des gens de cette sorte sont
capables de demander pardon ne serait-ce
qu'au chien ou au chat qu'ils ont
martyrisé pendant des années sous mes
yeux vous leur faites vraiment un crédit
ce sont vraiment si vous voulez c'est
même pas les Thénardier c'est de la
barbarie ils sont des barbares piago
d'autres choses dont j'ai pas parlé dans
je ne veux pas parler parce que ça va
déclencher une polémique mais il y a
plus grave que les coups vient de
d'achever podium 2 on l'a lu Benoît et
moi il y a dix jours mais on est en
train effectivement de vraiment préparer
podium 2 là ça le scénario est achevé
je vous tiendrai au courant mais voilà
c'est en cours
vous pouvez nous en livrer un peu plus
fort
non je peux pas vous dire des acteurs
Jean-Paul Rouve normalement dans le
couscous
j'ai envoyé à Jean-Paul le scénario avec
quelques jours j'attends évidemment sa
réponse avec impatience je serai heureux
qu'il soit tous réunis et puis il y aura
aussi des nouveaux voilà avec une sortie
2023 était 2023 j'espère que je peux
vous dire Nathalie c'est que le premier
était clocloé à mort le 2 va être
polaire polarisé à l'excès c'est
l'équivalent du 1 mais Paul version
Polnareff donc le héros ça va être
couscous vous y êtes allé avec Gérard
Depardieu absolument un documentaire en
tout cas il y a des images et de la
matière il y a de Moix qui peut voir le
jour peut-être franc avec vous le film
est fait il est monté il y a plus qu'à
le mixer il dure deux heures et demi
je crois que ce film je dis franchement
je crois que c'est un film
extraordinaire
peut-être même un chef-d'oeuvre mais
j'ai rien fait moi j'ai filmé Gérard
encore je crois que c'est un film
hors-norme mais je crois aussi que ce
film restera peut-être pas sur mon
disque dur mais il y aura peut-être
se perdre dans les limbes des fanatiques
hardcore et qui circulera sous le
manteau parce que je crois qu'il n'y a
pas un seul distributeur un seul
producteur aujourd'hui suffisamment
courageux pour le proposer à qui que ce
soit c'est à dire qu'il y a un procès
par phrase c'est un film extraordinaire
au sens étymologique du terme c'est un
film fou
mais je et aussi parfois un tout petit
peu ennuyeux parce que la Corée du Nord
ça doit être ennuyeux c'est pour ça
qu'il dure 2h30 mais je crois que le 21e
siècle n'est plus possible n'est plus un
réceptacle possible pour ce genre de
folie pure